大家好
台灣股市4天漲了2300點
不好意思 我的台灣50又大賺了
應該賺了1500萬了吧
我真的懶得數多少錢
因為我的股票更飆
台灣股市4天漲了2300點
為何今天開高走低
我是不是有預測出來
好像有預測喔
成交量再度破兆
散戶回來了嗎
恭喜各位散戶 恭喜各位
可是有些事情回不去了
什麼事情回不去
第三個 錢放在銀行定存
是最傻的投資方法嗎
好像是
國巨何去何從
我今天所有飆股一次介紹完畢
大家好 我是摩爾投顧的投資長
也是全台灣唯一百萬
不只百萬 也是全台灣唯一
140萬粉絲的分析師
合格分析師
大家好 我是哲哲
你沒有聽過哲哲 你一定是股市菜鳥
今天國巨拉起來了
我就跟你講嘛 這些股票
不只是國巨
國巨今天漲停板
最後沒有漲沒有關係 慢慢來
我說既生巨禾伸堂
禾伸堂700多塊
國巨沒有理由 不要說700塊
沒有理由 不要說742
他現在742
沒有理由站不上700
趕快來 最近很多百貨公司週年慶
都還在
你去看101好像在週年慶辦活動
很多在週年慶
投資朋友 重要嗎
我要告訴大家
重點是台灣股市還在週年慶
你去看禾伸堂
2492華新科
我有請會員進場
我昨天暗示你我有買了
我說我這麼多會員沒辦法做假
你要的是哲哲
據統計有一半的人
還在被套牢 在被動元件被套牢
據統計還有一半的人
被動元件被套牢
可是我是你們的另一半
不是親密關係的另外一半
而是我是另外一半不被套牢的人
我今天還看網路上有人說
哲哲你看國巨今年讓人家賠多少
我想說奇怪
怎麼那麼多同業亂講話
我的國巨有讓你們賠錢過嗎
今年國巨有讓你們賠錢過嗎
早知如此 何必當初
是不是就像我說的
你看國巨漲停就漲停
你們自己看重播
你們知道我們今天會很大聲
來 等一下隨時準備爆麥好不好
看哲哲的節目首先要件
耳機或手機要好一點
不要爆音
來看一下
我說禾伸堂比國巨的股價高
沒有意義 來看喔
看我的預告
國巨我跟你講
我跟你講禾伸堂明天再噴一根
我跟你講禾伸堂明天只要5%
你記得我的預告
禾伸堂如果明天再5% 是
國巨明天會接近漲停板 真的嗎
我覺得機率滿高
來 我覺得機率滿高是不是
真的啊
禾伸堂噴出去5%以上
國巨就拉了 國巨今天
這麼大型權值股
全台灣哪個分析師
像我一樣喊水會結凍
我不像那種什麼網紅
有些人一看就知道
那根本就自己偷買股票
我真的不要點誰
那個我一看就知道
自己偷買股票然後拉上去了
自己走掉
我不去做這種事
我不做 我告訴你啦
國巨怎麼出貨給你
光國巨就438億了 一天
我讓你知道
什麼叫喊水會結凍的分析師
不用 大戶也不用吃哲哲豆腐
我也不吃你們豆腐
你們要買要出隨便你們
I don't care
就是要這樣有魄力的分析師
昨天直接跟你講國巨漲停
誰可以像我這樣子
你告訴我 Tell me
我們今天來看一下
大家的留言好不好 來看一下
聯電噴了 群聯上不去
你們要這樣抱怨 娃娃
這個還不會 抱怨我沒辦法
可是你看哲哲的留言就開放著
太多人了
所以代表沒造假嘛
有造假一定說哲哲你這個騙我
不用 我不屑啦
來看一下 今天直播人數3476
你們真的是讓我很難過
你們知道我今天要臭屁一下
人數就給我減少
不要這樣子
今天節目關掉好了
粉絲訂閱 我要付費才能看
以後下跌我要把節目關起來
今天直播人數怎麼那麼少
快氣死了
前幾天還8 9000人
今天3600是怎樣 來
哲哲說國巨500以下閉著眼睛買
我已經忘記有沒有講過這句話
可是我那時候用力買
那時候是我給瑤姐
我給主動型ETF信心
你看我人多好
00981A 你自己看00981A
主動統一今天還可以漲快2%
主動統一 00981A有沒有看到
今天還拉上去啦
這一波如果我台灣50
我不買台灣50 我買00981A
現在應該賺25%左右吧
1億大概賺2000多萬
我還少賺1000萬
我管你台灣50怎麼樣
我還說如果我有錢
我可能會買主動型ETF
不是分析師的話
或甚至買國巨 環球晶有沒有講
賺更多
你們不要羨慕我台灣50
我賺什麼1500萬
如果我不當分析師
我不當分析師至少賺
2500萬到3000萬啦
我可不可以買正2 可以啊
只是我告訴你
我身為一個分析師
我沒有推薦正2這個東西
我還是要講一件事
人各有志
其他分析師我沒有要批評他
因為我是全台灣最紅的分析師
我覺得投資上
我一定要高道德
我已經跟你講了
我不知道有沒有人亂用
我不知道台灣股市
有沒有哪一天萬一崩盤怎麼辦
他可以到10萬點之前
先崩個2萬點
你們受不了啊 懂嗎
所以我寧願少賺一點
我也要讓大家知道
正確的投資觀念是什麼
這就是我的使命 懂嗎
我就是台股的傳教士
OK嗎 知道嗎
我就喜歡傳教士
你不要想歪啊
導播你在想歪 你看
你在侮辱宗教
我真的是
幹嘛笑那麼開心 害我破梗
害我笑出來
我是台股傳教士 知道嗎
記得這件事 好不好
導播這個色鬼
來 看一下
哲哲愛你
哲哲廢話不多說 一句我愛你
我也愛你們
不論男生 女生 我愛你們
我就是你們的
股市的另外一半
回到我的重點
我又想起來我的名言
你有沒有想到
我的名言是什麼
華新科也是一樣 國巨也是一樣
國巨啦 華新科啦
來 大家留言
想不想聽我講話
來 國巨什麼意思
我講到那句
有沒有想到我那句名言
什麼
我知道你還有錢
還有一句
我叫你All in就All in
我叫你重壓就重壓
我叫你漲停 他就漲停
天啊 台股成交量 市值
什麼前幾大
今天應該有沒有前三大
應該有吧 助理幫我排一下
看一下第幾大
市值前三大的公司
你還這樣拉起來
到底多少粉絲
多少大戶看我的節目
多少基金經理人看我的節目啊
是不是 OK嗎
太準了 按讚了
世界先進等一下跟大家講
華邦電還是有機會噴 好不好
智原也有機會 都有機會
可是智原要比較久一點
會飛的哲哲豬
對 我就說我是豬
只是我知道哪邊有風口
我往那邊做就飛出去了
就這樣子
時勢造英雄 懂不懂 OK嗎
我是浩浩 我愛哲哲 看轉折超準
謝謝
不用一直自我介紹 兩三個
如果同樣的話貼超過三次
就要暫時停止發言
你要跟那個芝妍要表白是不是
我們這邊變成
哲哲可以對我傳教士嗎
你是男生
你想紅 我點你一下
來看一下
沒有啦 跟你喇低賽
哲哲輔導長
對 我以前是輔導長
輔導長以前不好考
現在 不重要
哲哲是一位有使命感的分析師
我先跟你講 我已經很臭屁了
來喔 包含那個1.74億美債
我都說我想要換台灣50
放到現在我少賺2億
少賺2億沒有錯
你們去算一下
現在是可以3億7台幣
我很大方 然後我也跟你講
我在買台灣50的時候 最低檔
我有沒有在最低檔
我真的是很大方的人
我有沒有在台灣50最低檔的時候
前一天我說破4萬點我要買
有吧 導播有沒有 有
沒有我們下台一鞠躬
賠大家1億好不好 好
我說破4萬點要買
剛好是最低點這一天
我明明知道破4萬點要買
我也告訴你
我說隨便換個00981A
隨便換個國巨 換個環球晶
都賺比較多
我有沒有講
我如果放到現在
台灣50你不要看我賺1500萬喔
我是少賺1000萬以上
我至少可以賺個2500萬到3000萬
我大不大方
我沒在乎錢啦 懂不懂
我在乎的是感覺
所以我就不懂
為什麼有些同業他們惹郭哲榮
我根本不在乎我的律師費要花多少錢
你懂不懂
我根本不在乎
跟你耗一輩子也沒關係
因為我覺得
有時候我就是感覺派
我就是希望大家賺錢
我希望大家開開心心
就這樣子
我告訴大家啦
這幾天有一個新聞 來啦
景甜 有沒有看過
那個好像環太平洋的女星
有沒有聽過
還有長城嘛
然後也是張藝謀嘛 是不是
那個男主角是麥特戴蒙嘛
最近很有名的麥特戴蒙嘛 有沒有
前男友6000字長文爆料
5000萬美元待遇爭議
有沒有看到
這個也可以扯到AI啦
女生有沒有看到
景甜有沒有聽到 很有名啊
說他有背景
中國大陸的女明星
38歲了
我不知道為什麼要把人家年紀寫出來
好了 人家可能想生小孩
38歲有沒有聽到
現在鬧出來3000萬人民幣的訴訟
大概1.2億台幣啦
1.3億吧
這個孫宇晨有沒有看到
這個是某個虛擬貨幣的創辦人
身價號稱80億美金
大概2500億啦 85億
2019年拍下巴菲特的午餐
這個男生真的小氣 為什麼
他跟景甜要回什麼
1.3億的台幣 為什麼
他說 不好意思
我現在不跟你結婚了 錢要還我
男生這樣說
真的很小氣
這個很八卦
陸續你會聽到八卦
最近真的很多八卦
你不覺得男女之間都是錢的事情嗎
很痛苦喔
你們不覺得自己多賺一點錢比較實在
你看陳幸妤也是
是不是 還有那個誰
Joeman也是啊 是不是
因為Joeman那時候被人家講的時候
我連那個什麼
那個避孕藥他都要自己花錢 是不是
這是他講的 不是我講的
對方那個Joeman的前女友
都是錢的事情嘛
我就說了
不能心委屈了 錢委屈了
但是這個男生這樣做很誇張
為什麼 因為他說景甜喔
不好意思啦
景甜說要跟我懷孕沒關係啦
我要找代理孕母
你要再給我15億台幣啦
懂不懂 再給我15億台幣啊
男生想一想 他問了AI啦
AI怎麼說
AI勸他不要付款啦
扯到AI上面去啦
所以這Claude
叫他不要付5000萬美元
他就不付了 你懂不懂
其中還有一個細節啦
孫宇晨啦 這比較18禁
沒有關係 你們都18歲才能做股票
他有碰女生的胸部啦
然後女生說 不好意思
你要碰沒關係 你要修指甲
你指甲太長了
你不覺得這個男生很沒水準嗎
不給人家5000萬美金就算了
當然你覺得景甜可能
有些人覺得女生愛錢
我覺得Whatever
那你們兩個私下解決就好了
不想跟人家在一起扯到什麼AI
還有人說AI幫他省了15億台幣
AI幫他省了15億台幣
然後呢 還把他們兩個撫慰的細節
撫摸的細節講出來
女生嫌男生沒有剪指甲
還幫他磨指甲磨了一小時
說來說去不就是錢
大方點嘛
學哲哲或學別人都可以
所以最好的方式自己賺錢 懂不懂
最後分手的時候
重點是分手的時候幹嘛寫出來
幹嘛還要跟他要1.3億台幣
是不是
你要給就
要嘛就不要跟女生要這個錢
要這個錢就不要
還要寫得你好像多癡情一樣
還要寫這些細節
沒水準 真的沒水準
男生真的 我很不屑
再多錢我都不屑
所以你看哲哲節目有三大保證
第一個 怎麼樣
絕對會剪指甲
看一下我剪指甲
來 導播看一下
臨時叫他
你看一下我有沒有剪指甲
絕對有
我就是愛乾淨
我有剪指甲有沒有看到
來 拉回來
看哲哲節目 三大保證
我手沒有抖 我有剪指甲
我愛乾淨 好不好 要求自己
體格管理 體態管理
投資道德管理 要求
第一個 絕對剪指甲
第二個 絕對不會跟前任要回1億
我會告訴你
你要賺 我們來賺錢
1億買台灣50 賺1500萬
買個國巨 賺2000萬
開開心心 大家都不要吵
第三個 我絕對不爆對方的料
我只爆飆股的料
大家好聚好散 懂嗎
看哲哲節目 三大保證
不錯吧 重點是很好笑
絕對剪指甲
那個景甜真的很誇張
男生真的不要這樣
不是 你要回錢就算了
就不要再講細節了 好不好
你說有些人覺得
我結婚聘禮嘛
沒有結婚的那聘禮拿回來
我是覺得就不要拿了 是不是
你要拿就不要還裝大方
說對方很愛錢
沒水準 真的沒水準
我很不屑
我比較老男人 你知道嗎
我覺得男生是要
我是大男人個性 你知道嗎
那所以有時候
我覺得心地算好
但是有時候個性比較機車
就是比較大男人
可是我覺得大男人的好處就是
我不會去算這種東西
實在是 你知道嗎 好不好
那哲哲缺人嗎
剪指甲是什麼梗
我會剪指甲
是不是 OK
第一次看哲哲直播
幽默大方又會剪指甲
真的會剪指甲啦
你知道嗎 我有時候帶去
比如說帶去哪邊國外
我會剪指甲
剪指甲怎麼挖鼻孔
還是可以啊 蹭蹭蹭就好了
好不好
時事這就是哲哲的厲害之處
來 看哲哲節目前
你們不用剪指甲 我來剪就好
你們不用選飆股 我來選就好
你們不用爆對方的料
我來爆飆股的料就好了 懂不懂
好恐怖喔
哲哲的節目越來越多元了 好不好
真的 你看那個陳幸妤也好
Joeman也好
哪個不是因為錢
你分手的時候
跟股票分手的時候
就不要想一定要把它賺回來
懂不懂 你要跟國巨分手的時候
你不要想說把它賺回來
是不是 真的
你想要賺回來 OK
那你就趕快加碼嘛 是不是
男人 女人會背叛你 錢不會
只有你背叛錢
這句話也不錯
不要說背叛 就是可能會分手
錢不會 你不會想跟錢分手
是不是 OK嗎
會員的世界
等一下我再看一下好不好
最近操作不敢說百分之百 好不好 OK
談戀愛
現在股票和期貨絕對不能放空
談戀愛怎麼付出怎麼痛 來
剪指甲很重要
你想笑死我嗎 謝謝大家
欣興今天被檢調搜索
要看情況 被搜索不代表什麼意思
今天有看到欣興的新聞嗎
我看一下 好不好 來
助理幫我查一下
以前看哲哲影片的時候
想說怎麼有人講話這麼討厭
訂閱數還這麼多人
還有人說我訂閱數全部打廣告
你也拜託一點
是沒看過我辦演講的人數
結果看著看著
就是說都是假人
結果看哲哲的節目本來也很討厭
看著節目就上癮了 他完全了解
我講話就是比較誇張一點
習慣就好了
不誇張你怎麼看
誇張 可是問題是誇張裡面有睿智
哪有人敢像我這樣預測
你告訴我哪有人
然後10次裡面可能對9次
有人就拿那一次來笑我
莫名其妙 你懂不懂 OK
哲哲觀念很好 要剪指甲
記得要剪指甲
記得現在要剪指甲好不好
好啦 鈔能力 追上時事
來 指甲縫有點黑黑的
真的假的 嚇死我了
沒有啦 你不要嚇我
你知道嗎
你跟我說我指甲有點黑的
比說我鼻毛長出來的更是一種污辱
這個污辱可大啦
我真的會剪指甲 好不好
鼻毛長出來就算了
因為你知道嗎
因為有時候我鼻毛長很快你知道嗎
真的 我鬍子長很快
我有時候一定要刮兩次
好啦 這個跟大家講
來喔 所以有沒有看到
有些誇張 非常實在
哲哲你國巨看到多少可以賣
來 今天好多人喔
我們來看一下
今天有很多人問世界先進
世界先進講得很誇張
世界先進不是那個嗎
火燒世界先進嗎 對不對
今天欣興漲可能說
那通常火燒世界先進可能會先跌
今天世界先進也沒跌啊
你懂意思嗎
有時候越燒越旺
我記得好像之前欣興好像燒了以後
就開始慢慢的一直漲 一直漲
邁向1000塊
不是嗎 我記得沒錯的話
世界先進 平常心啦
OK嗎 平常心好不好
來 這是我跟大家講的
所以我們來看一下這些東西啦
來啦 國巨我有想一件事情
你們有國巨的人怎麼辦
我告訴你好不好
我認為要逢低加碼
你注意一下
逢低加碼國巨
我就做一張梗圖給你看
會陪你到台股5萬
你不加碼國巨
要賠我5萬都不夠
一個是陪我到台股5萬
一個是賠我5萬
很多人說不好意思
哲哲我早就知道國巨會漲了
所以我提早進場了
我在1200元的時候提早卡位國巨
那現在500塊 600塊 700塊
為什麼你不買
今天漲上去也差不多600塊而已
是不是
多少 597
更好 600塊以下
還不買喔
你是不會看量喔 各位
這個底部爆量啊
會噴啦 AI會噴
你自己看黃仁勳講的話
我跟你講 你們都是因為
台灣的分析師 真的不是我要臭美
這樣講好像要批評人家
我講一個現象
我花最多時間
今天我在Threads
如果你們有看Threads就知道
年輕人就知道
很多人說Threads 哲哲
這是不是小編寫的
不好意思 全部都是我寫的
我可以想那麼多梗
我可以做那麼多研究
你告訴我誰的腳步
誰的思考速度能跟上哲哲
這樣講話很臭屁 是事實啊
我有梗也不需要去抄什麼網不網路
我告訴你隨便都是梗
心情一開心
我一天可以想個2 30個梗
然後人家就會覺得哲哲
為什麼你可以選股票
為什麼你可以重訓 為什麼可以跑步
所以我花很多時間
我花最多時間在AI上面你知不知道
其他分析師真的沒有花那麼多時間
他們很多人根本看不到AI的未來
我用AI我覺得好恐怖
可以多少的運用層面
我再給你一個簡短的一件事
怎麼會有人會覺得AI沒辦法變現
你們覺得就是企業不會買它
或企業沒辦法賺錢
你有沒有想過一個
還有一個人會買AI 誰
所有的國家啊
我要發展AI
我的國家要不要投資AI
那這些一定要馬上變現嗎
不是 他投資了不是就變現了嗎
不就是給廠商錢嗎
每一家企業 每一個國家都要投資AI
你們越用AI會覺得恐怖
在搞什麼
不過我最氣的是
我希望台灣政府
趕快通過台灣FSD好不好
不要輸韓國好不好
我們什麼科技之島
連個FSD都通過不了
拜託大家寫信陳情一下好不好
我買個特斯拉到生灰塵了
AI真的很好用
但是台灣的法律要趕快通過
拜託一下
扯遠了
我們也不是要變成批評政府好不好
藍綠白 到時候各個縣市
就是反正北部縣市 南部縣市
我答應你們嘛
第三台救護車嘛
選南部的縣市 這樣好不好
OK嗎 第三台救護車 好不好
每台救護車要500萬耶
三台就1500了
這是檯面上的喔
檯面下的哲哲也捐很多了 好不好
只是不需要每天一直講
我只要講救護車就好 來
算不完啦 OK
每天必看的節目
哲哲投資長星期六也開播嗎
看情況 大漲大跌再播
哲哲以前是工作狂
我現在有稍微工作強度降低了
可是你不用擔心
摩爾投顧現在很多分析師很認真
業界最認真的都在摩爾投顧
你相信你的老師
然後很少 我沒有要針對誰
很少錄影然後跟你說很認真
我也沒辦法
你要相信我也沒辦法
可是人在做天在看
你看到我們摩爾
你看到比如說基鼎老師
我每天叫他休息 他還是錄很多
他真的很認真
很像10年前的我
也很誇張 真的很誇張
哲哲不好意思
因為哲哲已經當分析師當了20年了
所以我要有一個節奏最重要
重點是績效好比較重要
可是如果節奏對
我覺得績效反而更好一點 OK嗎
哲哲真的太神了
一堆看衰國巨的分析師
唯獨你排除
因為他們 我不要講誰
因為他們為什麼看衰
因為他們只是用感覺而已
他們不知道AI可以解決一切
就像哲哲的愛可以化解一切 懂嗎
後面那句話是幹話
前面是認真的啦
AI是真的 黃仁勳怎麼說
你看我都做字卡
我也都比人家漂亮
是不是 拉遠
加碼國巨 要逢低加碼啊
你們國巨要逢低加碼啊
你1200的 你不加碼沒有用
你要逢低加碼國巨
你才會陪我到台股5萬
你不加碼國巨
你賠我5萬都不夠啊 各位
賠你5萬都不夠
來 景氣紅燈這個也做嘛
是不是你看我都做的圖都特別漂亮
你告訴我為什麼
黃仁勳 千載難逢機會啦
很多人說他借太多錢了 有沒有
他覺得啦
一樣投資太少 也沒有更早投資
OpenAI或Anthropic
或夠快上市有沒有看到
馬上賺錢啦
你們都把那些有錢人當白癡
然後你們都
很多人都把有錢人當白癡
你們最聰明
看啊 你看巴菲特
買那個 笨蛋白癡
人家就算虧掉一半的錢
還是比你一輩子賺的錢多100倍
你懂嗎
你看 早知如此何必當初
不要買 不要買
最笨的就是把錢放在銀行
給你看啊
我今天做這張字卡啦
伊朗的股市
前幾天540萬點有沒有看到 沒錯吧
現在638萬點有沒有看到
638萬 大概漲20幾%
助理怎麼沒寫漲幾%
20天漲20%有沒有看到
差不多
快20%有沒有看到
是不是每天漲
為什麼伊朗的每天在漲
為什麼你知道嗎
因為通貨膨脹
貨幣貶值 資金避難所
你聽不懂沒關係
我問你啦 伊朗在打仗
是不是不值錢了
誰會想要伊朗貨幣
不會有伊朗貨幣
那東西不值錢了
早餐會不會變貴
幣值貶很慘
不像台幣現在在漲嘛
台灣如果發生戰爭
台幣也不值錢
那誰值錢
早餐值錢 食物值錢啊
東西值錢
因為你的貨幣貶值了
你的錢不是錢了
你新台幣100萬
雖然還是100萬
但是你本來買東西 你本來
譬如說你本來買一個
100萬有什麼東西 我想一下
1000萬好了
本來你買1000萬的房子
現在變2000萬
你本來買100萬
譬如出國旅遊100萬
你現在要變200萬
類似這樣子 突然沒想到
十支手機 你本來要100萬
現在買十支手機你要200萬
錢變薄
100萬實際上
以前100萬可以買十支手機
現在100萬只能買五支手機
這叫錢變薄了
錢變薄 東西要越買越貴
股市也會啊
所以伊朗發生戰爭 股市在狂飆
再講一次
伊朗發生戰爭怎麼樣 股市在狂飆
再講第三次
伊朗發生戰爭 股市在狂飆
一堆人說
我每天擔心台海發生戰爭
你擔心什麼東西
台海發生戰爭
我覺得很快就打完了
不是我們贏就對面贏
就這麼廢話
台幣會貶值
懂不懂 台幣貶值怎麼樣
會跟股市一樣 股市會狂噴
因為我買東西會變貴
我東西 我台幣100萬
我的價值會變成50萬
原本100萬能買的東西
只能買50萬的東西
所以錢變薄了
所以我的股市也變貴了 聽清楚嗎
所以最傻是把錢放在定存
尤其是你每次都說台灣最大危機
是台海危機
你為什麼把錢放在定存
把錢放在銀行
把錢放在銀行是最傻的
股市可以抗通膨
可以抗戰爭通膨
有沒有跟你講這東西
沒有啊 你們的分析師每天漲停啊
好無聊 漲停啊
要幹嘛 然後給你每天講漲停要幹什麼
我很不屑
我要是老投顧
我現在講30分鐘漲停板
我是要幫你們 告訴你們
建立正確觀點
不要去亂融資 懂不懂
不懂你就買台灣50
再不懂買00662
我希望10年過後
哪一天我不在舞台上面
你們會懷念我一輩子
這是我的使命 知道嗎
我是傳教士
導播不能笑了
我真的是傳教士 結果我先笑
記得我說的這句話
所以你看 最傻
你看我買壽險 要幹嘛
我買那些保險要幹嘛
一樣 錢到時候會變薄
發生戰爭的時候
台灣要是發生戰爭
或是惡性通膨的時候
戰爭一定會惡性通膨
戰爭惡性通膨的時候
股市會保值啊
因為東西會變貴啊 懂不懂 OK嗎
台積電收美元的啊
台幣貶值它反而賺更多
懂不懂我在說什麼
這樣懂我的意思嗎
每個戰爭都在拖
錢變薄了 來
我來站台了
OK 人家的鳥
什麼鳥瘦精什麼
好啦 就跟大家講
欣興什麼時候啦
傳教士 我看一下欣興
一直講欣興要幹嘛啦
我現在也沒有他啦
他只有寫副總跟會計
副總跟會計又不是公司的老闆
就算公司老闆
也不代表整家公司啊 你知不知道
來 所以你看喔
2327國巨
2327國巨再噴出去了
有點累了 休息一下
現在突然沒力了
不好意思 哲哲現在是那個Streep
那個 你知道
美國的影后
Meryl Streep
沒力了 我沒力Streep
好不好 來
精材現在進場會不會太晚
也不會啦
可是精材的主力
中實戶啦 我用中實戶
磨滿累的 感覺他現在要噴出去了
感覺已經吃完了
可能甩不掉哲哲
或者也知道哲哲做長的
不管了 我要拉了
我就說了
台積電資本支出概念股
都可以噴成這樣子了
我跟你講 還記不記得
我以前買萬潤
100多塊被人家罵
100多塊跌下去
然後跌到7 80塊跟欣興一樣
現在都1300了
不要到時候精材真的給你噴出去
我跟你講 你真的會愛上我一輩子
好不好 愛上我一輩子
精材 還有呢
還有6488環球晶
今天漲很少
不用擔心 隨時有機會噴出去
我們看三大法人
投信昨天小買小賣
大部分是買的 有賣一點點啦
沒有關係
因為我做的有時候甚至比投信長
短的拜託不要來看我
你覺得你是短的不要來看我
我比較長一點
我看得比較長一點 OK嗎
5483中美晶 3532台勝科
台勝科感覺是籌碼
可能台勝科籌碼比較簡單
你看台勝科投信買成這樣子很誇張
硬是要拉啦
看得出來台勝科要漲上去了
好啦 我突然覺得我現在沒力
我要休息一下
導播我休息一下
好不好 我答應你
休息一下 大概2 30秒
休息完以後 馬上回到活力的哲哲
歡迎回到現場
哲哲喝個水 休息一下
我剛才休息的時候看一下留言
哲哲你說不要買壽險 不要買保單
會不會得罪人
對不起 因為滿多
應該是保險業務員的
或者有些人是靠
爸爸媽媽是保險業務員
然後成家立業的
修正我的話
我覺得買一些保險 可以
尤其是壽險
你真的出事了
你留給家人都OK
不用買那麼多
不要買有關投資的保單
這樣OK吧 這樣我講的夠中立吧
可以買 我覺得你們有些人需要買
但是你真的很有錢的時候
最好的不是買那些什麼保險
你出事了 然後保險
最好的是像我一樣
一年花10幾萬做健康檢查
你花個3 4萬也可以 好不好
做肺癌的 做斷層掃描 知道嗎
還有做什麼
斷層掃描是不是有四個英文單字
我突然忘記了
LDCT是不是 忘記了
應該是LDCT 你查一下
做電腦斷層掃描
然後做大腸鏡 好不好
真的是這樣子 OK嗎
這些比你那種事後
我得癌症了
然後保險公司會不會給我錢
還是某一條文沒有寫
你身體不好 你可能不能申請
或者不是這個病
還要看法律條文 幹嘛
做健康檢查才最實在 好不好
把三高壓下來
該吃的藥就吃藥
好不好 OK嗎
沒十幾萬 不用啦
十幾萬是我比較愛花錢
你3 4萬就夠了 好不好
基因檢測 我有做基因檢測
沒有用
我花了十幾萬
那個沒有什麼答案
我不知道是不是因為那一家
不能講我是做哪一家
我最近有稍微跟你講哪一家
不是 那個沒有意義
基因檢測沒什麼意義
可能現在有另外一種基因檢測
我不知道
也可能或許我很健康
低劑量電腦斷層 對
真的相信我好不好
要正確的投資觀念
可憐 可悲 可惜 對啊
你看
哲哲寶貝 哲哲大大可愛寶貝
我聽你的建議國巨從1020
攤平到647元
你有錢為什麼不攤平 你懂嗎
攤平你只要有錢
你就不要怕攤平嘛
你如果是融資當然不建議攤平
你看1020攤平到647元
等於說下禮拜國巨再一根漲停板
他解套了
你們這些人都是這樣子
哲哲可不可以1200
奇怪咧
明明有機會讓你打8折 打對折
多買一間你不要喔
多買一個你不要喔
屈臣氏加1元然後送一件
你現在再加個半折
再多送一件不好嗎
多送一個國巨不好嗎
來 什麼最新新聞
來看一下
3 4萬健康檢查推薦什麼
我剛才已經講那兩個了
大腸鏡跟LDCT
低劑量電腦斷層 肺部的
華新科可以續抱嗎
華新科比國巨強多了
為什麼不續抱
有沒有搞錯啊
要噴了啊 我昨天還畫這條線耶
你不要鬧 我還說這條線突破了
你不要鬧
我是捨身取義
我買目前最爛的國巨耶
你們不要鬧 知不知道
華新科早早鎖死了耶
那個現在大戶叫做圍魏救趙
我利用 也不算圍魏救趙
我應該說 我利用禾伸堂
拉抬禾伸堂來救國巨
你們知道嗎
因為我去買禾伸堂以後
大家覺得被動元件應該一起漲
比我本身去拉國巨來得好
我已經告訴你圍魏救趙了 好不好
就是現在大戶 中實戶很聰明
我拉個禾伸堂
現在成交量100億
總比我去拉國巨拉個400億好吧
差300多億耶
我拉個禾伸堂 拉完以後對不對
我還可以順便去當沖
我去沖華新科 知道嗎
做價差 這樣就可以賺5 6%
可能可以賺幾千萬 幾億
我拉禾伸堂
然後去當沖華新科 當沖國巨
然後去救我的國巨
摸蛤仔兼洗褲 一魚三吃 懂不懂
我用低成本的
低市值的 低金額 金額比較少的
我去圍魏救趙
我用華新科的漲停 說錯了
我用信昌電的漲停 禾伸堂的漲停
去救華新科 去救國巨
就這樣子而已
哲哲不說破而已 我現在教你
這樣懂不懂
我怎麼不知道中實戶 大戶的想法
哲哲是靠股票賺錢
只是要不要說破而已
沒關係 因為這是良性的反應
我當然講了 沒差啦
所以有些股票為什麼我不碰
有些生技股為什麼我不碰
網路上傳誰認養那些
你們沒有他們的關係
你就不要認養那些奇怪的生技股
沒有關係就不要去認養好不好
那是籌碼戰而已
不要亂買生技股
那是大人的世界
康霈你沒有認識裡面內部人員
就不要買了
你要認識內部 要真的很認識
就不要買了 OK嗎 來
欣興電子 我也說過了
兩副總一會計 那不要啦
就算整個公司也沒關係
他不要是說什麼
營收造假就好了 你懂我的意思嗎
內部有人掏空 怎麼樣的還好
人數6500有很多嗎
直播人數6500很少
至少恢復起來一點點
台幣貶值對資金是不是會抽離
對股市不利
可是現在台幣是升值
沒辦法 現在台幣是升值
是升值好不好 往下是升值 各位
從32.58兌1美元
變成31.67兌1美元
你用比較少台幣就可以換1美元了
是升值
升值完以後你再去買那個00662
或者買那斯達克ETF
我最近應該幫00662做了蠻多事情
我真的是
我明明可以收會員賺很多
或者自己做股票賺很多
我選擇最奇怪的
常常推薦你們一些怪怪的ETF
沒有啦 這沒有怪怪的
只是你們不知道而已
哲哲中美晶怎麼看
我中美晶講完了 不要鬧
群聯還要鬧多久
不敢講每一檔啦 好不好
群聯就算沒有噴出去
我覺得華邦電也有機會噴啦
好不好 OK嗎
記憶體今天休息一天
你讓它休息一下嘛
每天噴也會受不了 不是嗎 來
華許今天不是有那個Fed
不會講什麼話啦 華許
我跟你講新聞創造話題而已
華爾街創造話題
有些分析師創造話題而已
一個Fed新任主席
居然開會的次數要減少
你覺得他會想講什麼話
他話越少越好啦 懂不懂
他就不想講了啦
他不想讓你誤會 你懂不懂
就像葛林斯潘說過一些預告
他就說你不會知道我在講什麼
如果你知道我在講什麼
那是因為你不知道我在講什麼
類似這樣的話
他不會讓你知道他在講什麼的啦
懂嗎 華許也是一樣
都要把會議次數砍半了 減少了
把Fed會議次數減少了
這次全球央行年會不會講多少的東西
其實0052有某方面 0052更飆
就像你問我那斯達克還是費半指數而已
要飆的就買費半的ETF
普通飆的就買那斯達克ETF
0052我很喜歡
0052的績效是狂屌打那個
只是台積電的比重更重
哲哲很厲害 昨天說國巨會大漲
是不是 我還跟你算時間
那最無聊的就是有些網友
哲哲那你可以告訴我
明天的國巨
明天國巨不會動 明天禮拜六
哲哲禮拜一的國巨
我怎麼知道
有時候是個感覺
感覺又不是每天都發功
每天都通靈
每天通靈的你去看連續劇好不好
偶爾通靈就很厲害了 懂不懂
來 下週到700元嗎
這個問題就有點過分
已經跟你講說很難知道
就算知道我也會跟會員講
來啦 我已經給你們免費試吃了
Costco你要免費試吃
你要先加入會員
我又沒叫你加入會員
所以不要問那種那麼細節的 OK嗎
我看一下
欣興檢調搜索
傳涉假帳 內線交易與洗產地
如果假帳 內線交易 洗產地
我不知道 假帳有兩種喔
一種假帳是說
洗產地嘛
他的假帳是洗產地的話就還好
就會像那個美超微一樣
你知道嗎 美超微一樣
就是像做AI伺服器的
所以你們要告訴我新聞嘛
助理也沒告訴我新聞
這個東西 助理
如果是洗錢 如果假帳是那種
不應該給這個客戶賺錢
結果你居然
你不應該賣給中國
然後你居然賣給中國 會被抵制
但是影響
會影響喔 還是會影響
禮拜一如果傳出這個消息是真的
有洗產地或涉假帳
只要涉假帳這個字
禮拜五應該會半根跌停以上
理論上是這樣子
如果這個假帳從頭到尾
就是這個營收是灌的 全部都是灌的
完全沒有人買
或者是你現在有人買
你只是透過
比如說我賣給馬來西亞客戶
實際上我是要
透過馬來西亞客戶給中國
這個也會影響
因為以後就不能賣這個了嘛
以後就不能增加這個營收嘛
賣給馬來西亞 馬來西亞賣給中國
實際上你根本就是
原本就要賣給中國
那這個假帳會影響
但是影響不到非常誇張
如果這個假帳影響是
從頭到尾營收是假的
沒有這個實質的客戶
也不是要賣給中國
或賣給什麼第三方
就是假的營收
那死定了 那就不只一根跌停板
兩三根都有機會 兩三根以上
這是我的判斷
因為你現在數據資料不多
可是你告訴我
哪個分析師敢跟你講這些
沒有 事後話
你看我的股票漲停
你知不知道有些老投顧
就是看今天哪個股票漲停 然後去追
你還是有人要被騙 我沒辦法
你看 你們問我問題
你們都每天最新新聞問我
都直接問喔
你告訴我哪個分析師有這個能力
很多都是背資料的啦 懂不懂
欣興說假帳 內線交易
欣興我已經過去的情人了 好不好
過去的情人
我不要當恐怖情人一直罵他
我已經跟你講了
欣興是我過去的情人了
以前70塊的時候
被人家罵很凶 你知道嗎
過去的情人 你記不記得這件事情
你們忘記了嗎
我說我對節目有三大保證
第一個 會剪指甲
第二個 絕對不跟前任要回1億台幣
第三個 絕對不爆對方的料
我們過去就過去了
只爆飆股的料 好 扯遠了啦
神奇寶貝
國巨跟禾伸堂二選一選什麼
我想要放棄一個了
傻瓜 都要啊
兩個都要 為什麼要放棄 來
台積電年薪600萬
還要繳稅 600萬至少要繳100萬的稅
你知不知道
對 差不多 600萬差不多
對 沒錯
600萬的話
至少要繳140萬的稅
因為500萬的年薪大概差不多
如果他沒有把家人 小孩算進去的話
或老人算進去的話
大概是要扣100萬的稅
至少要扣100萬的稅啦 600萬
那有比較好嗎
股票基本上不用繳什麼稅
這是事實啦 好不好
來 明臭什麼東西
扯遠了 現在幾分鐘
45還好啦
我們來看一下我們的股票
趕快把它結束掉
總是要臭屁一下
精材今天漲停有沒有看到
恭喜 來 導播幫我唸一下
我們興奮一點
好 8月25禮拜五 今天的簡訊
恭喜3374精材
股價開平一路走高
直接衝上漲停
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺98%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
精材98%
有沒有看到我信手拈來
隨便問我個欣興 隨便講個東西
什麼景甜也好 或什麼資料也好
我好多梗 好多資訊
我大量資訊 然後告訴我哪個分析師
每個人都看衰國巨
看到航運股強講航運股
看到CPO強講CPO
哪個人像我這麼有道德 是不是
不能說他們沒有道德
你們邏輯要對喔
你們去比較一下
精材這樣不離不棄是我兄弟啦 是不是
這個都跟大家講
9月9號下個月開始要摺疊手機
我新日興好像之前賺錢還賠錢走
我記得 我已經忘記了 應該是賺錢
現在摺疊手機要拉起來 有機會喔
因為這次聽說賣的
我會想要買摺疊手機
可是它不是Face ID
我已經習慣Face ID了
我可能會買兩個手機 都買
就是兩個新手機都買
試一下看看哪個比較好
這個跟大家講 新日興 OK嗎
這個跟大家講
ADR有1.5張借券
沒有什麼意思 借券沒什麼意思
有時候做套利又怎麼樣
不要一直重複問題
重複問題超過三次 沒看到就算了
助理有些人重複超過三次問題
洗版那就先暫時停止發言 好不好
這個又第三次了 我有點生氣了
不要啦 不要一直重複
兩次好不好 不要說生氣啦
因為你們洗版
你要記得一件事 我不是網紅
雖然我行為有些像網紅
我是專業分析師
我還是要養那麼多的研究團隊
如果你又想問那麼多問題
你又不參加會員
那沒意思 你懂我的意思嘛
每個人都每個人的Quota
真的好不好 所以不要一直洗版
兩次就夠了
洗版 然後重點又是針對你的問題
那就沒意義了
你就是想要免費又想要哲哲一定回答
我又不是傻瓜
真的不要這樣子好不好
資本主義的運作還是這樣子一件事
也是要贊助我們一下
我沒有強迫
我沒有要求你 強迫你贊助
但是你不能要免費的
一定要我提供服務
這就沒意思嘛 對不對
我說的沒錯吧
你覺得不錯就參加會員嘛
來 群聯
這邊哪有怎麼樣
剛才不是講過了 群聯沒什麼
就跟華邦電一樣
我氣死了 剛剛講過
奇怪 很多人就很厲害
就不會說 精材你好厲害喔
沒關係 我們自己厲害就好
今天本來想吃薯條三兄弟的 為什麼
因為我國巨 華新科
連禾伸堂都漲停了
其中國巨 華新科我們都有發簡訊
是不是 被動元件三兄弟都漲停了
本來想吃薯條三兄弟
冷笑話啦 好不好
這個鴻海沒動
量出來會慢慢來
如果你覺得慢的話
是可以考慮換股啦 好不好
3374精材真的要噴了
我覺得大戶真的要噴了
看還有沒有沒講完的 差不多了
好啦 來
不論哲哲 對
大家覺得華新科真的有買嗎
那是你沒有看昨天的節目好不好
華新科
剩幾分鐘了
念完就結束了
恭喜2492華新科
可能要講別的
股價跳空噴出
開盤10分鐘就衝上漲停
被動元件回溫上漲
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
華新科有沒有看到 漲停
國巨呢 今天也漲停
就大概漲7.5%
恭喜2327國巨
跳空開高一路急拉
成功鎖上漲停板
我們買進到現在
最高已經獲利20%
我持續看好它 少量持股獲利續抱
投資朋友 我是真的很恐怖
今天很多人說為什麼開高走低
我最後給你看這個東西就好了
看了以後你就會覺得很恐怖
櫃買指數有沒有看到
有點開高走低有沒有看到
大盤也是有點開高走低
你知道為什麼櫃買指數會這樣子嗎
因為我昨天就預告了
最後給你看這個預告
可是預告完你就覺得我好恐怖 真的
我再講一個預告 有沒有看到
剛才有預告國巨
我再講一個預告
因為我剛才講的不夠直接
人家漲4% 台灣漲2%
台灣股市接下來很容易開高走低
開高走低不代表一定收跌
像今天也算開高走低
或者開到中間漲高 尾盤殺下去
厲不厲害 開高走低
因為台灣股市已經接近新高了
很恐怖 連開高走低都預測到
你看大盤也是有點開高走低
是不是 早盤高點在這邊
開高走低 上櫃指數也是一樣
你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
開高走低也預測成功
國巨說漲停也漲停 預測成功
華新科說漲停也漲停
精材也漲停就漲停
你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
不要國巨800元了
然後群聯創新高了
精材創新高了
一堆股票創新高了
環球晶1000塊 2000塊以上
你說哲哲你好神喔
神什麼 神奇寶貝
重點是你要擁有他
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
也預祝各位
趕快加入我們的行列
預祝各位賺大錢
謝謝各位 Byebye